hey and welcome to another hd tutorial
this one i'm going to be showing you
exactly what youtube wants from the
people that upload their videos to their
popular website
so what i'm going to do is just hit my
youtube button it'll take me to
youtube.com and pardon my slow internet
connection here i'm using a few uh i'm
actually downloading several programs
right now
uh for reviews so i'm just gonna go to
youtube.com
and if you go hit the upload button
right here you'll notice there's a
little new
little tab here that says capture videos
in hd they're trying to give you tips
about how to upload your videos so if
you click on that more information
button here's the whole help center on
how to optimize
how to optimize your videos so that they
are perfect for youtube so this is a
summary of the audio and video specs you
need for the best results on youtube for
further details just look below so we're
going to look below
and right off the bat we see a
recommended resolution for your video
which is 1280x720 that happens to be the
hd resolution in youtube if you can't
avoid it then you may uh you can upload
in 640 by 480 which will get you that
little high quality link and but it will
not be in 16x9 and won't be in
widescreen so you'll have little black
bars on the left and right of your video
now the one i'm uploading right now that
you're watching is 1280x720 so you can
see oh whoops
so actually you can see that this is um
this is high definition
content that you're watching
also they recommend a bit rate and a
frame rate and here's a recommended
codec this is my personal favorite h.264
but there are plenty of other products
you can use
so
i wouldn't worry about your audio i'm
using a two channel audio
um
sorry i'm using two channel audio
because i have two microphones that are
hooked up so if you're listening to this
you will hear um
audio from both channels
alright so that is the audio part of it
second when you scroll down you will see
that they're telling you originals
please this is uh best basically how to
get this youtube quality out of your
videos when you're actually so i'm going
to scroll down to you that when you
first take a video and upload it to
youtube you're going to see when you if
you've recorded in 16x9 in 1280 by 720
resolution then you're gonna get that
full youtube screen that you're looking
at right now
the widescreen youtube format and if
you've taken the video in four by three
aspect ratio then should only have a
black bar on either side of the video it
shouldn't be both sides of the video and
the top and the bottom as i go here it
shouldn't be completely messed up so if
you've if you've actually made a 16x9
resolution
and youtube plays it in four by three
you do not want this because then
like say you've encoded it in four by
three then you have black bars or gray
bars at the top and the bottom of the
video and then in youtube there will be
black bars at the left on the right so
this is not what youtube wants
frame rates uh
are generally not that important this is
24 to 25 frames per second yields the
best results for youtube so that's what
i'm going to recommend right now
and resolution like i said 1280 by 720
is hd and i also do other other youtube
resolutions that work just well
especially when recording your screen
like i am now
so that's basically it um there is no
facility to re-upload videos so it is
important that you test everything
before you release it to youtube so i'm
just gonna you know
every time you upload a video and do
your editing just walk through it the
entire time and make sure it all works
out so i hope that um answers any of
your questions about what youtube
actually wants in their videos and
that's about it thanks for watching
peace